et on passe aux invités du 7-8 week-end
avec moi deux libraires du pavé du canal
à montigny le bretonneux elodie persico
bonjour et l'écart chemin bonjour vous
êtes venu avec votre sélection de livres
à la fois des bd à la fois des livres
pour adultes on va commencer par vous
elodie alors qu'est ce que vous avez
dans votre besace
alors moi j'ai essayé de faire un petit
tour rapide des coups de coeur de
différents rayons donc on va commencer
par un album jeunesse qui est vraiment
leur de g voilà fleurs deux géants de
nicolas poupon donc là ça a vraiment été
un coup de coeur de libraire au pluriel
parce que je ne suis pas seul et est
donc c'est l'histoire d'une toute petite
fille mais vraiment tellement petite
qu'elle ne trouve sa place nulle part
et donc elle va partir de son monde où
elle n'est pas acceptée elle va tomber
sur un géant qui va lui demander de
d'être sa souffleuse parce que les gens
ne peuvent pas lire de lui raconter des
histoires voilà donc voilà les les gens
ne peuvent pas lire de livres parce que
il n'y a pas de livre assez grand pour
les géants donc faut bien qu'ils
trouvent une solution
alors ils ont une petite bibliothèque
dans leurs oreilles et ils ont besoin de
petites sommes et de petites femmes pour
leur lire des histoires en face à partir
de sa partir de 6 ans à partir de quand
même beaucoup de textes donc partir de 6
ans on va continuer avec un autre livre
qui s'appelle kevin beau très beau un
autre une autre bande dessinée alors
cette fois-ci bande dessinée oui donc la
fête on peut dire dont pour donner des
idées d'âge à peu près à bâle à partir
de 5-6 ans un certain va être un peu
plus jeunes voilà là c'est très très
beau donc c'est le grand retour de chris
dessinateur bd qui fait d'être très
belles choses mais assez rarissime mais
heureusement est donc là il fait son
grand retour avec une histoire
album alors c'est un tome 1 mais on a
une histoire complète donc je pense
qu'on retrouvera ses personnages et ses
animaux dans d'autres tomes et avec
grand plaisir d'ailleurs
donc voilà donc c'est l'histoire d'un
vieil éléphant et de son ami grincheux
lyon qui vont venir d'un roi lion voilà
il ya beaucoup en lisant l'album on
retrouve wii beaucoup de dessins animés
sont reconnaîtront donc sakhaline boal
album jeunesse à partir de 2,50 on va
peut-être partir chez les grands
maintenant avec peut-être green manor
alors green manor donc la green manor
c'est une petite pépite ce sont trois
albums qui sont sortis il y à bien plus
d'une dizaine d'années maintenant
et là le dieter a décidé d'en faire une
intégrale que je trouve vraiment
magnifique qu'ils ont tous bien
travaillé la couverture est superbe et
puis voilà c'est pour tout lecteur parce
que ce sont des lords anglais qui décide
en lisant le journal dans leurs fumoirs
de résoudre les enquêtes à la place de
la possible de la police donc c'est bien
beaucoup d'humour très très bon so
british parce que j'en suis entre en
rien les images peuvent atteindre et les
spectateurs et c'est so british
kamel or donc ça c'est plutôt pour c'est
pour les haïtiens c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de lecture bon un classique jeu
se passe on te dira un classique mais
bon on va reconnaître avec la couverture
le dernier termine alors le dernier
tardy donc là c'était un petit peu
facile de le sortir mais vraiment il est
tellement beau
donc pour le coup c'est un vrai tome 1
tardive et un père qui était très dur
avec lui et un jour ils parlaient sans
arrêt de la guerre et un jour tardy lui
a demandé et ben d'écrire sur la guerre
de sortir un peu tout ce qu'il avait et
il son père l'a fait mais il a rempli
plusieurs carnets et il tarde il les a
laissés de côté en se disant un jour
peut-être
et puis bah ce jour est arrivé et donc
ils racontent ce que son père a vécu
voilà donc quand prisonniers quelques
jours de guerre avant d'être prisonnier
pendant plusieurs années
c'est très poignant c'est
c'est moi j'étais très intriguée par le
format parce qu'on a des très grandes
cases je me suis dit mais l'histoire ne
va pas avancer et en fait si on n 13
voilà c'est très épais et c'est ça
fourmille de détails fins et assez assez
c'est beau pas drôle mais beau alors on
va quitter un instant le monde de la bd
pour un grand corps malade
voilà c'est un livre mais c'est
d'ailleurs là c'est un lion mais c'est
un coup de coeur
donc moi c'est un personnage que j'aime
beaucoup encore malade
on voit là et que je suis allé voir
d'ailleurs sur scène
et quand j'ai vu son livre ça m'a
interpellé je m'attendais pas forcément
à lire son accident mais
et puis surtout plus tard sa
reconstruction mais c'est écrit avec
beaucoup de justesse c'est pas du tout
larmoyant on arrive à sourire et à rire
ce qui est moins agressif occasion
d'écriture et poétique quand l'écriture
est magnifique les christian fx700 550
pages poignantes et qui reste vraiment
en tête c'est très très bonne culture de
plusieurs des livres sur des libraires
et figure dans l'entrée de la librairie
une certaine délicatesse et un dernier
petit livre très amusant oui assez
inattendu vous voyez là c'est alors veux
la lui il est sur table parce que
l'humoriste y voilà donc alors là ils
ont sorti quelques années les 90 livres
cultes et puis les 90 films cultes
ils ont décidé d'en faire une
compilation donc c'est quatre cases
dessinées avec quelques phrases pour
raconter un livre entier d'une cabale à
vous êtes alors l'étranger mais c'était
la sage de juste voilà voilà capable de
servir d'aiguillon on prend ça comme ça
on n
alors moi jusqu'à ce trophée holy drôle
c'est d'avoir lu les livres et de les
voir résumer en quatre ans canal up
assez c'est très c'est très juste
d'accord c'est à 0,90 libre culte et 90
films cultes merci pour votre sélection
a passé la parole à vous y regardez
alors vous et laissez les vivre
on va peut-être commencer par le prix
goncourt des lycéens est pris grand prix
de l'académie française voilà l'étonnant
ce cas la fois c'est un auteur qui est
félicité par les jeunes est félicité par
les moins jeunes à sainte-félicité par
les jeunes alors qu'il fait à peu près
650 pages est tout le monde se disait
jamais les jeunes ne vont lire 650 pages
et là nous avons une enseignante sur
saint quentin en yvelines qui fait
partie du jury en effet du concours donc
qui a piloté un peu l'opération elles
étaient ébahis de voir l'intérêt que les
lycéens
et c'est vrai de tous les prix
littéraires ce titre c'est la vérité sur
la sphère harry québec c'est un jeune
c'est son deuxième roman
c'est un suisse de 27 ans est vraiment
au niveau de la construction c'est tout
à fait bluffant au niveau de l'écriture
c'est une très belle écriture jusqu'à la
fin on est pris c'est qu'il ya une
intrigue policière dedans mais également
des histoires de entre des écrivains et
de livres puisqu'en fait ça parle de
plusieurs livres totalement bluffant une
construction très original jusqu'à la
fin on est pris en haleine donc la
vérité sur la faire arrêter bersac vous
avez forcément dur entendre parler parce
que sans doute on améliorait riz le
meilleur prix littéraire de cette
rentrée un autre livre blanc cette
émission avait parlé je trouve ça très
amusant c'est à quoi jouent les hommes
c'est un livre étonnant
voilà christophe de nerfs qui est donc
un écrivain connu tout à fait bailly
l'activiste c'est à dire les jeux et il
joue beaucoup et notamment au pmu et
autres et voilà donc un roman qui l'a
écrit sur en effet le pmu est en fait on
apprend l'histoire du pmu sa création
ses originalités
pourquoi les le tiercé et en même temps
c'est aussi sur les questions
aujourd'hui de cette addiction que
certains ont vis-à-vis du jeu alors
c'est un bouquin en plus très bien écrit
je pense que pour les gens qui ne disent
pas beaucoup c'est marie qui ne lisent
pas et qui qui joue plutôt au pmu c'est
un excellent pour les labos camion voilà
exactement et carvin ya pas que les
messieurs qui ont fait mieux au sida
et donc alors ça c'est vraiment
incroyable chrono historique romande
aujourd'hui questionnement aussi sur la
nature du jeu est vraiment on apprend
beaucoup et tout médire sur les jeux
c'est quand même assez vite avant tout à
fait et je suis pas du tout un fan de
jeu mais là j'ai été bluffé et
intéressés jusqu'au bout par le livre
bon roi christophe d'honneur à quoi
jouent les hommes je trouve ce livre
très intéressant pas sur sa
problématique est assez amusante le gars
du tir là on part alors bien on part en
chine alors c'est un livre qui vient
d'avoir pas mal de presse et
d'information c'est un effet un livre
d'actualité un peu policiers ou en fait
c'est un grand dignitaire responsable du
blanchissement l'hélium naissent en
quelque sorte de la chine qui tout à
coup se pointent un consulat américain
et livre les secrets de la chine
c'est une histoire authentique sur une
base authentique alors bien sûr l'auteur
a été obligé de construire entre les
éléments qui sont connues par la presse
et la réalité et on comprend et on voit
le fonctionnement de la chine du parti
communiste des dignitaires c'est
vraiment passionnant excellent roman
policier d'actualité philippe de sert-il
le guet du tigre pour ceux qui se
passionnent pour la chine
fabrice humbert et professeur au lycée
franco allemand de buc et publie son
quatrième troisième par nos ouvrages
avant la chute voilà avant la chute donc
fabrice humbert fabrice albert c'est
vraiment un écrivain qui monte qui
figure sur toutes les listes de prix
littéraires il a pas encore eu un très
grand prix mais ça ne saurait tarder une
très belle écriture toujours sur des
questions d'actualité
là vous avez une question de 3 comme
d'habitude il a un espèce de mosaïque de
personnages vous avez deux soeurs qui
sont des colombiennes qui veulent aller
aux états unis qui aux commandes au
début ils ont avec leur père faisait de
l'élevage normalement en colombie et
puis on les inciter à passer bien sûr à
la drogue
et puis l'armée est venue elles ont
voulu fuir épicé leur itinéraire jusqu
aux états unis elle n'y arrive pas elle
s'arrête au mexique où là elle rencontre
un sénateur
c'est toujours un peu cette question
mosaïque de personnages comment des gens
ordinaires à un moment donné
franchissent la ligne journées
deviennent des sans s'en
apercevoir
et puis une troisième partie qui est lié
donc à des problèmes de drogue dans les
cités dans les cités les banlieues en
france
remarquable très bien documenté comme il
l'avait fait pour la fortune de sila qui
était vraiment un remarquable bouquin
également donc fabrice humbert avant la
chute et jean paul professeur au lycée
franco-allemand donc exactement corps
exhalent yvelinois de surcroît est le
dernier livre les eaux et louise c'est
un livre plutôt historique voilà chez
actes sud des éditions actes sud
bizarrement c'est écrit par un allemand
mais c'est une histoire qui se passe
totalement france ça commence avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale où un effet un
jeune grands en faisant du vélo
s'aperçoit une jeudi mignonnette et
autres dans le nord de la france et puis
et puis et puis à ce moment-là il y a un
peu ont rejoint le tardy et le début de
la débâcle
ils sont éloignés une histoire d'amour
ne se fait pas et puis c'est toute leur
vie et leur rencontre depuis cette
période avant la guerre jusqu'à
maintenant puisque ça commence avec le
décès de de leon belle histoire d'amour
on apprend énormément de chose en plus
et des choses que moi je ne connaissais
même pas sur la résistance au quotidien
vis à paris pendant l'occupation donc
les excellents romans d'amour également
léon et louise donc alex capuche pas si
on prononce comme ça et aussi une très
très belle écriture
merci pourquoi vous d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour nous donner quelques idées
de peut-être de cadeaux de livres à
faire pour cette fête de fin d'année
merci beaucoup à vous deux et enfin donc
d il y aura des dégâts ce week-end
samedi je le dis rapidement samedi et
dimanche
il ya deux journée de dédicaces
notamment à kirby gare le samedi
alexandre à combiers plasticienne le
dimanche et en plus si vous venez le
dimanche a livré du pain et du canal à
montigny on aura droit des desserts
c'est ça tout à fait tilt et à tanguer
que c'est su faire à partir de livres de
classe que de nos rayons donc des petits
gags serait bien pour tout le monde
merci à vous deux